as Manchester United hosted Everton
today it scored a record of different
sorts this the club's 4,000 consecutive
match with at least one youth graduate
from its Academy on the side Marcus
Rushford and Jesse lingard both England
players and two of United's brightest
stars but their success began as
children at the club they now play for
in the Premier League the 4,000 game run
for Manchester United youth graduates
began before the Second World War back
in 1937
perhaps the to stand out areas for
homegrown talent were the so-called
Busby Babes who played under the
management of Sir Matt Busby in the
1950s and of course the class of 92 I've
always said there are values that
Manchester United has that should never
change and that's they should play
entertaining football obviously always
try and win trophies but always have an
essence on the fact that the academy is
something that's been so special to this
club and Gary Neville joins the wealth
of homegrown names in 1956 Sir Bobby
Charlton made his debut for the first
team in the 60s the mercurial George
best broke into the club's senior team
in the 80s the Academy produced a number
of great goal scorers including Mark
Hughes the famous class of 92 featured
some of United's biggest names including
the likes of David Beckham and Ryan
Giggs and today the likes of Marcus rash
furred they're carrying on the club's
great tradition of championing young
talent and Fletcher moss Rangers is the
tiny grassroots Club where it all began
for Marcus Ratchford
with 400 young players aged between 6
and 17 it's one of the many pipelines
into competitive club academies all's we
can do' a grassroots level is give a kid
a chance it's up to the powers that be
United Cities whoever it is you know to
actually take the golden nugget polish
it and make it into something you know
that can be used further down the Round
Room you know in the football world as
it were and there's certainly no
shortage of ambition here what you want
to be when you grow up what do you want
to be when you grow up
it's this confidence that's nurtured at
the academy according to United graduate
Paul McShane he never played for the
senior team but he says the experience
teaches you more than just football
everything was a competition you know
was they you know we played hockey we
play badminton we'd be we'd be swimming
and it was always that having that
mentality of want them to win and then
that was I was throughout the whole Club
train and every day was was there was
competitive you didn't want to be on the
losing team an Academy player Mason
Greenwoods goal against Everton is a
timely example the value in growing your
own talent
Sally Lockwood Sky News at Old Trafford